[Music]
[Applause]
okay so where are we going
actually that's just one of the
questions that's raised in this famous
painting by Paul Gauguin where these
people are asking themselves some very
basic questions about us and our place
in the universe
so the complete set of questions is what
are we where do we come from
and where are we going and those are the
questions that I want to discuss I'll be
at somewhat briefly in this talk so I'm
gonna be discussing it from the point of
view of a physicist and as a physicist
you know I look at the universe around
us and what does it look like well we
know it's expanding and it's been
expanding for something like 13.8
billion years and right now it's about
the visible part is about 10 to the 28
centimeters across
okay so if we now rephrase go gas
questions what is the visible stuff in
the universe
made of what happened back in the
beginning of the universe that's where
we come from and what's the long-term
future of the universe but it continued
to expand will that expansion rate
accelerate as it seems to be doing at
the moment okay so I should specialize a
little bit I am a particle physicist so
I'm going to be talking the language of
particle physics oh I'm afraid so if I
want to rephrase go gas questions what
are we that becomes a question what is
matter made of and I'm going to be
spending a time period of time
discussing one particular aspect of that
question which is wider things way why
do the fundamental constituents of part
of matter have mass where do we come
from what's the origin of matter can we
explain the origin of the matter in the
universe in terms of the poverties of
the fundamental particles constituents
of matter
astronomers tell us that in addition to
the visible matter in the universe that
you and I are made of there's also a
whole bunch of invisible dark matter is
that some sort of particle that maybe we
can detect in our experiments how does
the universe evolved well Einstein gave
us the equations for that but you have
to put into those equations the
appropriate equations to describe the
behavior of matter
why is universe so big and old maybe
that is also something that we can
explain in the language of particle
physics what is the future of the
universe okay
so that is what I get paid to do and
that's what we particle physicists do
for a living to try to address these
questions and provide at least some
answers and the answer to this question
up here why do things weigh has been
provided by Peter Higgs whom you see
here smiling somewhat and we'll come
back to him in a moment the other
questions there again to acquire
additional physics beyond that that's
already been established and I will
discuss some of the possibilities for
answering those questions later on in
the talk okay so this is a ruler with a
logarithmic scale yeah is there anybody
else here old enough to remember slide
rules a whole lot of you you look so
much younger okay so on this slide all
we've got the size of the earth in the
middle you've got the size of the
universe 10 to the 28 centimeters over
there and we've got the smallest scale
we speculate about the beginnings of Big
Bang 10 to minus 32 centimeters over on
the left-hand side and the human scale
is roughly speaking half along half way
along here is represented by Albert
Einstein and his kid sister about a
meter tall so of course we know a fair
amount about what made up Einstein and
his kid sister we know there are made of
molecules as molecules contain atoms
those atoms were made of nuclei with
clouds of electrons around the nuclei
contain things called protons or
neutrons
fundamental constituents of protons and
neutrons are objects that we call quarks
so a particle physicist will tell you
the fundamental constituents of the
visible matter in the universe electrons
and quarks and related particles now an
astronomer looking up at the stars will
say yeah that's all well I'm fine those
make up the visible stars in the
universe but they're held together in
galaxies by this additional invisible
dark stuff that I mentioned a moment ago
and of course we particle physicists
wonder whether that Dark Matter might
not be some type of elementary particle
and what we do is we do experiments for
example the Large Hadron Collider at
CERN where we try to create new types of
particle and study you know the
properties that occurred very early in
the history of the universe when it was
a fraction of a second old so as I said
I am a particle physicist but there's
always been a close connection between
particle physics astrophysics and
cosmology so the physics of the very
small and the physics of the very large
that's exemplified by the fact that many
of the fundamental discoveries in
particle physics in the first half of
the last century were made using cosmic
rays these are energetic particles that
come from explosions in outer space
those produce energetic particles they
hit the atmosphere when they hit the
atmosphere they produce lots of other
particles and many new types of particle
were discovered that way in the first
half of the last century for example
antimatter we shall be returning to
later on antimatter was first discovered
in the cosmic rays but around the middle
of the last century physicists realized
that if they wanted to study those
particles in detail and measure their
properties accurately they needed to do
controlled experiments in the laboratory
and so they decided to make their own
cosmic ray collisions using particle
accelerators and colliders so what are
those experiments reveal as being
the structure of matter so they revealed
something that we call the standard
model of particle physics so this
standard model was proposed by Abdul
Salam originally from Pakistan named you
see here and to American theorists
glasha and Weinberg and their theory
which they proposed in the late 1960s
was based on ideas proposed by Peter
Higgs and others also in the early 1960s
and it was tested by experiments at CERN
some of those experiments extremely high
precision for example here if you look
very carefully you can see a little red
dot that's an experimental measurement
the Green Line is the theoretical
calculation they agree perfectly well in
fact that's even a cheat because that
little red dot has been blown up by a
factor of 10 so that you can see it just
tells you how well is the agreement
between the theory and the experiment ok
so what does the standard model contain
so I talked are you on about the quarks
that make up nuclear matter I talked
about the electron there's a couple of
similar particles the muon that was
discovered in cosmic rays and another
one called the town
there's neutrinos which I'm not going to
have very much time to talk about those
are the fundamental constituents of
matter and then between those
constituents we distinguish four
fundamental interactions so we've got
gravity what is familiar with that
electricity and magnetism unified by
James Clerk Maxwell
while it was at King's College London in
the 1860s and then inside the world of
particles we've got a strong nuclear
force that holds nuclei together and a
weak nuclear force that's responsible
for forms of radioactivity ok so I like
to think of what you see on this slide
as in some sense being the cosmic DNA
that encodes all the information you
need to make all the visible matter in
the universe including Donald Trump I
should say that's how Donald Trump is
made not why
okay well I actually cheated a little
bit because what you see on that slide
does not explain well the masses of
elementary particles come from it's
important that the electron has a mass
because if it didn't it would always
travel at the speed of light
fly away from nuclei never make any
atoms never make any molecules never
make any us for example so mass so we
all probably have learnt something about
mass right Newton told us that weight
was proportional to mass you may
remember from school w is equal to mg
but what M what's the mass Einstein
energy is related to mass E is equal to
MC squared what is M where does the mass
come from and that's where this
gentleman here Peter Higgs comes in and
that's his theory they're on the
blackboard behind him now just in case
you have difficulty in remembering his
theory you will be able to see it for
the rest of the talk because it's on my
t-shirt so the top line explains
fundamental interactions the second line
how those act on fundamental particles
of matter the third line is how Higgs
give masses to the fundamental particles
of matter and in the bottom how it makes
the weak interactions weak everything is
on the t-shirt to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit a I
dot TV for more debates and talks from
the world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas